you don't have what we're doing with
this you're gonna get better at sex
you're gonna get better
CrossFit is terrifying
Darwinism tire throwing
[Music]
we're going to start today with a 300
meter on the two rounds 15 push-ups 15
sit-ups 5 sumo squats
that was a warning
cheers like Bernie
you have with CrossFit called tipping
like some weird mating dance pull-ups
[Music]
LeBron this
[Music]
so this is another one it's a good core
workout at the top we have these two
loops that's kind of swings and perky
box it's like a top there I'm like
carrying a top there right now
we're doing Crossfit
[Music]
I like it but I like like the silly fun
we're done with everything Simone
CrossFit is really intense and I have a
lot of respect for people who do it
[Music]
I feel like I accomplished something
today yeah the the ending that what the
burpees was a thoroughly unenjoyable
while I'm more exhausted than I've been
in a while
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's great immediately after that I
was positive that I would never recover
but what I thought was cool about
CrossFit is I feel like it's a lot more
human than like going to the gym and
working on them literally a machine that
works one muscle at a time instead
you're using your whole body and feels a
little more cave minish little more
ground a little more real with mark
Naiman entire get out of here CrossFit
and I got split tires so I got it right